Chúng ta sẽ có một máy đăng trên mặt giá hội,
thử kiểu hội đồng Anh Ninh Quốc gia tùi cao Iran,
Anh Lý Lá Rí gia niên Tinh Bố, Iran đã chuẩn bị sẵn sàng cho một cuộc chính trang lâu dài.
Iran, kinh quyết bảo vệ đất nước và nên văn nền sống như năm 2019,
bất kể giả nào.
Trong thủ bảo phát thì cuộc này, lượng lượng vệ bình cách ngạc hồi dạo Iran cho biết,
kể từ khi xuống lộ cù phát Iran đã phòng hơn bể chăm thích bị vay hương
ở lại và hàng chăm thích lộ.
Bình công sống như một tiêu chiến lượng,
cùng năm 2018 của Mỹ và Israen tại Kuwait
các tiêu vũ của Arrog Thống nhất,
Bà Ràng và Yow Bình Hông MUSS.
Công một tiêu này bao hồn cân thứ quân sự,
chúng tôi mục cân và hạt tự được cho là phục vụ hạt động tắc chến.
Theo lượng phòng về Israen trong bàn ngày qua,
Iran đã thay đổi kích thức tấn công,
chuyển từ các phục phòng dài giá,
sàng nhất lợp bản tên lượng kinh mồ lớn,
nhịp lộ và tính tổ chức của các lợp tấn công trả đủ lần này của Iran,
tương tự cuộc chiến mời hai ngày của thằng sau đúng ngoái.
Iran tại thử định chính trình hạt nên của nước này,
hòn tuần vì búc địa khòa bình.
Và tế Ràng đặc thục thiệt quyền tự vệ
theo điều năm mốt của hình trường lên nập quốc.
Mọi phản đường của nước này là hấp pháp,
cân thiết và tương sướng.
Khi chính em vào các một tiêu quân sự.